all right thank you for the introduction
as he said I'm Cody and I'm an adjunct
at SDSU which which means they kind of
like me and I kind of like them but they
don't actually pay me it's the Dakota
Lakes research farm that pays me how are
we doing at the microphone we need to we
okay now a little better okay thank you
Sarah do I need to move this around
maybe or maybe get this out of here
maybe we'll work a little better outside
okay so I consulted the Dakota Lakes
research farm I have for the past
several years now and it's been a
fantastic experience for me I wanted to
start things today just by recognizing
my grandfather who passed away this past
year he when he was 14 years old his dad
gave him the choice of buying some cows
and raising cows or he could go to high
school and he chose to to stay on the
ranch and raise cattle
and because of his hard work throughout
his life and his generosity his kids and
his grandkids like myself didn't have to
make that choice between the cattle and
going to college and so I just want to
wanted to say thank you grandpa and you
know he's one of the many reasons why
I'm able to stand here today with with
education and with the background on the
ranch that I've got the impossible
burger you guys probably have heard of
this it's a it's a veggie it's one of
the latest veggie burgers right and when
you look at the picture the the whopper
on the left and the impossible burger on
the right they don't look a whole lot
different you know when they're
presented this way and I'm not here to
talk about whether it's a good idea it's
a bad
or good things or bad things about it my
interest in it is something else and and
there's the question of why will people
buy it and what does that mean for
people who might be raising livestock or
raising beef in particular and number
one on this list I've got up there is to
save the earth if you look at the
website from the the company that
produces the burger they're very
straightforward about saying that's why
they're doing this because they believe
their product is better for the earth
they're saving the earth if we're eating
the impossible burger rather than animal
products in our burger and like I said
I'm not going to go into what those
claims and whether they're they're
correct or they're not correct I wanted
to focus a little more on the other two
points the number two I've got there is
taste and then I've got the price you
know research has shown that people who
grow up eating grass fed beef prefer it
to grain fed and vice versa you grow up
with one thing you tend to like it
better and it's in my head I wonder if
you know people who grew up eating
veggie burgers might actually prefer
that to the to a regular beef burger in
any case there are a lot of people who
do eat it there are people who like it
and so it's it's out there people are
eating it people are going to enjoy it
right and finally and not not not that
everyone will but some certainly will
and then finally price if I understand
right right now the price is probably a
little bit higher than your regular
burger but this is a this is made in a
lab it's an industrial process and I
assume that they will get better attic
this is a pretty new product right
chances are they're gonna get better at
simulating the flavor of beef and the
eating experience of beef and they'll
probably get be able to do it cheaper
too and so what happens if they do get
that price point down to being the same
as a beef burger or less and they get
the taste to be pretty close what
happens in what are people going to eat
well I suspect we'll see a lot of a lot
of people choosing the burger right and
it might not be one or the other might
eat some one and some some beef and some
of the the veggie burger and right now
keep in mind less than 2% of the
our population in the States now they
say is involved directly involved in
agriculture so most people most people
are eating don't have a real clear
understanding of where their food is
coming from and the main choice that
they've got is something kind of like
this you know most of the beef is coming
through our conventional methods which
includes a feedlot and then we've got
you know the impossible burger on the
lab on the other side and when people
are presented with this choice some will
choose one some will choose the other
right that's that's the way it's going
to be but those don't have to be the
only two choices and that's what I'm
suggesting is another way that we may
produce some of our beef and I think
when the consumers are presented with
this choice that we'll get some more
people choosing to to eat beef and I'm I
want to put out there the idea of this
artisanal beef and I've got under there
wine coffee tea and chocolate those are
products that where this idea is already
is is already out there and I in the
back near the coffee there's a little
table set up there's a bottle of wine
and a box of tea back there I encourage
you to go back there read the labels on
those products because when you read
those labels you you find out all kinds
of information about how they were
produced what the soil was like and
maybe what the weather was like what the
guys name was who ran the vineyard what
this product is gonna taste like and you
get all this information before you even
you know open the bottle or the package
and I wrote there's some pieces of paper
there too I wrote up some examples of
what that might look like for beef in
central South Dakota and and I just the
idea the main idea is this sentence I've
got here down at the bottom tell people
how we care for the land and the animals
because if we're doing a good job of it
caring for the land of the animals we
want to communicate that message to
other people and chances are we can be
rewarded for it in the marketplace and I
think we can get a better price for the
products that were that we're producing
because there are a lot of people in
this world who are buying food who care
about how it was produced and they care
about how we how we took care of things
and I think that along with this there's
the opportunity to develop some terroir
for South Dakota beef this is a fancy
word usually you see it with in relation
to wine and the idea is that the
particular environment where those
grapes were grown impacts the quality or
in the taste the particulars later of
the wine and right now we think of beef
mostly as a commodity where it's all the
same but I think there's a lot of
opportunity to develop particular you
know tastes or flavors or terroirs of
beef and market it that way so today I'm
gonna I'm kind of gonna talk about
several different ideas and I'm hoping
that in at the end they'll all come
together and it'll make sense why why I
jump around a little bit in it we'll
have this constellation that comes
together that was the marketing part Kay
now integrating livestock with crops why
in the world would we do that because as
you guys know having livestock around is
a lot extra work they can be a real pain
in the butt especially if you're trying
to calves you know during the middle of
a snowstorm and so why would we do that
well some of the reasons on the left
that I've got some of your standard
crops on the right I've got some forage
and perennial crops if you want if you
integrate livestock in your operation it
gives you a lot of it gives you some
opportunities for Biological and
economic diversity so you could these
forage crops I've got on the right you
could grow those even if you don't have
livestock but the livestock if you grow
them and you have livestock now you've
got an opportunity to harvest them and
make some money at at the same time so
if you believe that you need more
diversity in your rotations if you want
to put more you know you want to grow a
cover crop after the wheat that you had
after you harvest your wheat and you
want to make some money on it at the
same time and not just put all of it
back into the soil that's where the
livestock come in and you can you can
make some money on it and because if
you're if you're just growing these for
for hay and you cut the hay and
you sell it to your neighbor or to
wherever your export you just lost the
benefit that you had most of the benefit
you had from from growing that crop
because you didn't keep the nutrients in
the biomass the organic matter right
there on your farm so you get the
opportunity for diversity and a couple
of these things here I have down to the
bottom alfalfa and switchgrass those are
both perennials you have the opportunity
now to put some perennials in the
rotation and make good use of them why
would we want to do that well this is an
amazing picture this is a big bluestem
plant you can see we're just a little
bit of green up on top and look at that
massive root system below it this is why
we'd like to have perennials in our
rotation for those massive root systems
that's one of the big reasons anyway and
in full disclosure these these plants
were grown in special containers you
know that allowed them to get nice deep
roots and then they can harvest them and
wash the roots out and make a nice
picture so there is that but they didn't
just go out into the field and dig them
up but you know these perennial grasses
like these these warm season native
perennial grasses like big blue stem
switch grass they can have roots that go
well beyond six feet under the right
conditions and so you know compare that
to our our annual crops which have much
shallower root systems typically but
even if they do get their roots way down
deep like say a corn plant it that corn
plants starting over every year so those
roots even if they do reach a pretty
good depth there's very little of the
growing season that they actually get
down to that depth whereas the perennial
has those roots down there all the time
once they get established so what are
some of the advantage of these deep
roots well nutrients going up so those
deep roots are extracting nutrients from
lower down in the sope soil profile
nutrients that your annual crop can't
get to and they draw those nutrients
back up incorporate them into their
bodies so so now after that perennial
has been there what your annual crops
are going to be able to access some of
those nutrients that have been brought
back
to the near the nearer the soil surface
wine being one of those examples another
reason to have those deep roots is
bringing the water table down that's
something that people are probably more
interested in now than they were five
years ago with you know those deep roots
there they're gonna be able to access a
lot of that water that's your annual
crops can't get to so now going
transitioning a little bit from the
ideas to what we're actually doing at
Dakota Lakes native tallgrass plantings
and we can point to an example of where
some of this idea came from in Argentina
there used to be a traditional practice
of having seven years of crop an annual
crop followed by seven years of a
pasture and so these pastures typically
would be a grass legume mixture and and
so they go back and forth and that's one
way they would maintain some of the
fertility of the soil at Dakota Lakes
we're trying something it's a bit
similar except we've got 15 years of
crop followed by five years of perennial
pasture now we just started this and so
I can't say that these are the magic
numbers that it's 15 and 5 right but we
believe that this is going to really
benefit the soils that we have in this
rotation during those 15 years of
cropping we still have a crop rotation
where so as you can see here we're gonna
go from winter wheat to corn or sorghum
and a cool season broadly so we do that
for 15 years and then we transition into
the perennial now this is so this is a
picture of our switchgrass so the
perennial that we've used so far this
first time around has been switchgrass
it's for the most part it's a
monoculture of switchgrass half of it
half of the field we designated for seed
production this year and harvested seed
off of it the other half we grazed and
we've grazed that for two or three years
now you can see the cattle out here in
July advantage by grazing of course is
that the nutrients are going back to the
soil in the organic matter
now one of the challenges with putting
that perennial in and only having five
years of of having that perennial in and
remember our objective of putting it
there is to benefit our soil now when
you start a perennial like a switchgrass
or something that first year a lot of
times they only get about yay big even
if you've got you know good conditions
and you're good a good stand you might
not get much growth second year they're
getting bigger but they're still not at
say maximum capacity
so there's establishment year down
second year we're doing okay but now
we've got two years gone by and we
haven't done anything for our soil yet
in fact because of the low productivity
in the first year I wouldn't even be
surprised if we returned less biomass
than usual so that just leaves us over
three years to this five year of a
perennial to try to to really do a lot
of good stuff for the soil and we're
choosing we chose switchgrass it's it's
a high biomass crop and it also has a
high carbon to nitrogen ratio so idea
there being that we're gonna put a lot
of carbon back into the soil to build up
that soil organic matter but we only got
three years to do it so something Dwayne
and I have talked about and we've tried
out is try to accelerate that at that
establishment process a little bit by
planting the switchgrass
in a year when we still have a grain
crop there so what we did last year was
we we planted two rows of wheat and then
a row of switchgrass two rows a wheat
and a row of switchgrass we also tried
putting the wheat and the switchgrass
together in the drill and planting them
all at once and then the other thing we
did we planted the wheat and then we
came back later and planted the
switchgrass overtop after the weed had
already come up and that last treatment
it appears that we we did damage our
wheat yields with that all three
treatments I went out there and counted
switchgrass plants which was rather
tricky because they're they're pretty
little but it looks to me like we
probably got a pretty good amount of
switchgrass out there in all of those
cases
not to say that you might not have to
come back and receive some but this this
coming well this growing year now when
things start greening up again I'll be
going back out and checking on
winterkill and that to see if the
switchgrass
survived because it you know we didn't
get very big especially being there
under that wheat canopy this is a
picture of a mixture of switchgrass and
big bluestem
this is on some heavy clay soils and a
pretty shallow soils heavy clay and this
picture was actually taken in 2018 which
was wet and a lot of parts of South
Dakota but it Dakota Lakes it was
extremely dry and it was just amazed me
how much productivity we got out of
these native warm-season grasses even in
a drought a year like that and this
picture was taken in July end of July
and it's it's headed out here and so is
in terms of quality I mean you can see
the cattle are here grazing this is not
great quality at this point it would be
better to graze it earlier in the year
but you know also depending on your
objectives if your objectives is to
return a lot of biomass to the soil it
can still meet that objective even if
the quality's low and so right next to
that we had some degraded rangeland and
I say degraded you know it didn't
include these warm season grasses there
were some native grasses some exotic
grasses and I just went out there and I
took some samples to check on the
productivity 3,600 pounds of
productivity at the on the native range
and about double that where we had
planted the switchgrass and the big
bluestem just amazing what they could do
now in terms of quality from a new
animal nutrition perspective the the
neither one of these is very good but
the the switchgrass and big bluestem was
was very poor quality but a key factor
here is this is taken on July 26th so we
wouldn't expect it to be very good that
time of year
another thing I like to do on the farm
we've got I want a lot of the field
margins we have switchgrass planted and
so you know we've got the field over
here switchgrass over here and in this
particular case we've got smooth broham
growing back here you can see it's it's
brown and it's headed out the date here
is July 8th of this past year and I'll
go a lot of times to these areas on the
farm and try to make a fenceline
comparison you know side-by-side because
a smooth brown that you know that's
something we have in a lot of our
pastures and if you've got cattle you
know you know it's really good forage
early in the year cattle love it it's
high-quality but what happens as you get
in you know towards the end of June into
July you know it gets mature same thing
with crested wheat grass you know
they're great early in the year but we
don't have enough cows to graze all that
lush green grass we have early in the
year we get into summer and then it's
not much good anymore so on this date on
July 8th when I took these samples one
either side of the fence
the switchgrass was three and a half
percent higher in crude protein than the
the smooth Brown was so that's that's a
big advantage now typically you would
think smooth bromes a better quality but
again it all has to do with the date
because at this time the the smooth
Brome was already mature this and the
switchgrass is kind of just getting
going in June and here in early July
it's still high quality so we've got
some good good quality for the cattle to
graze that time of year I made a similar
comparison for the past several years
I've made a similar comparison in the
ditches by Dakota Lakes switchgrass and
big bluestem on one side smooth Brahm on
the other side this year I actually
didn't find very much difference in
quality again this was in early July but
in past years I usually find in early
July the switchgrass and and big
bluestem are a little better than the
smooth bromb but in all these years I
find I will find that the we're getting
more productivity out of the big blue
stem and switchgrass than the smooth
bromb and that's you know in early July
that's the case
but they're not done growing if I waited
until later there'd be an even bigger
gap in terms of productivity for getting
more productivity from those tall
grasses rather than smooth broma
okay so now transitioning those are some
more of the planted stuff now
transitioning to a pasture situation
three years will ago Dakota Lakes rented
the pasture that's right across the road
from the farm and this pasture had been
continuously grazed for a long time and
mostly dominated by exotic cool season
grasses like crested wheat grass and
smooth bromb some we have some
cheatgrass and some Kentucky bluegrass
out there too and so we wanted to
transition it from that into more of a
more of a native dominated pastures so
specifically looking at putting things
in like the big bluestem and so in order
to do that we were tried a lot of
different strategies so we set up
experiment where we we sprayed out with
glyphosate so going north south we'd
sprayed with glyphosate or atrazine or
both or no spray at all and in this
picture you can probably you can make it
out I think that you know there's a
brown strip here and a green strip here
brown strip you know so you can tell
where those strips are so we sprayed out
and then and and I don't I don't I don't
want to advocate spraying good going out
and just killing everything in native
range land that's I have to give that
disclaimer because this I as a rangeland
guy I definitely don't want to suggest
that this is a case where we pretty much
had exotic species and I think a lot of
this land where we did it may have been
go back land it was probably farmed at
one time so mostly there wasn't a whole
lot of native that was that was left
there to spray but so we've got the
spray treatments going north south and
then we seeded going east west so what
we end up with is a big checkerboard of
treatments we did a mixture of grass is
mostly big bluestem
and then we did that also with some
forbs or some broad Leafs and then we
did areas where we didn't seed anything
and after and those first two years were
just bone dry at Dakota Lakes 17 and 18
and we saw very little results from that
but this past year we finally got to see
some of those grasses coming that we had
planted and what it looks like now is
that you know after three years where
the story's not over but so far what I
can tell you is that where we sprayed
glyphosate and where we drilled we had
fairly good success at getting some
noose grasses established there but if
we only drilled or if we only sprayed
neither one of those treatments really
worked and we did do one other thing one
other change in management besides the
spraying and the seeding and that's the
grazing so rather than the continuous
season-long grazing we've been moving
moving the cows in this particular
pasture sometimes more than once a day
in other cases you know maybe a day or
two and we don't do that all year long
we don't do that all the time but eat
with this this rapid grazing even that
was not enough to you know to bring
those species back on their own over
three years so there's kind of a lot of
caveats there I don't want to say it can
never happen but I think that this this
particular land where we were working we
didn't really have big bluestem there to
begin with - I don't know that if we
even had a seed bank left - for it to
come back on its own and one exception
to the rule of having to spray and drill
both is that we there were some areas in
the swales you know some wet areas if
you follow along these where the lower
places in the in the landscape where
it's wet some big bluestem that we
planted did come up there
even without herbicide in those spots
and what's circled there you probably
can't really make it out very well but
that is a big bluestem plant that's not
very big you know it's only about this
big and if there's a lot of that out in
this pasture and so I
think that over the next year or two
we're gonna see a lot more but the
chances are you know if we continue to
get a little bit of rain chances are
this is project is gonna look more and
more successful as time goes on three
years really isn't enough to judge it
and this picture is in here just to
basically show that there's a lot of
diversity out there in this pasture
which as an ecologist that's something
we always like diversity ok similar
issue but a little bit different site
now Dakota Lakes just this past year got
a lease on the land between the farm and
the river and so this is was the core
land now the game fish and parks has it
and there's a little spot there that's
just beautiful it's full of Indian grass
which is one of our native warm-season
grasses and Maximillian sunflower you
can see them here but this is the real
exception to the rule most of this land
is just like that pasture dominated by
the exotic grasses that we wish we
didn't have so much of it and I I loved
this picture because I took it on
October 3rd and most of the landscape is
brown and and you know there's no
flowers to be seen but this Maximillian
sunflower if you're interested in you
know wildlife and pollinators where else
are you going to find flowers like this
in October so one of the things we're
doing there we're trying to get those
grasses back and we're doing the rapid
grazing thing again and what we do what
we're focusing our grazing early in the
year in the spring because these are
those cool season grasses we're trying
to hurt them right and tip the scales in
favor of the warm season grasses that we
planted so we grazed this several times
really early in the year and the other
thing we did is we broadcast some seed
out there and then we just just did that
we also broadcast seed and rolled with
some bales out over top and then we also
drilled some spots and so you know this
is what it looks like in May or after
right after we've rolled the bale out
there here is in July there's still a
lot of it visible and and even into
September a lot of that bales still
visible in some places it was on
pretty thick and so to this point we
don't have many of those species that we
planted if not many of them have come up
I you know I looked around and I did
find a few plants you might even have a
picture yeah I'm holding one there you
can't really tell but there are a few
out there but Isis I'm hoping that a lot
of those seeds are still viable and as
the bail breaks down maybe we'll get
more of it out there and those bales we
used bales of mature switchgrass and big
bluestem so there was a lot of seed in
them as well okay now I'm gonna
transition to front front while all
those perennials to the lives the
cropping side of things but being an
ecologist even when I transition to the
cropping side of things I start you out
with a slide with bison and grass on it
right because because if I'm gonna talk
about a cropping system and trying to to
design it for wherever your farm happens
to be I think the FIR the place you need
to start is think about how mother
nature did things there and learn
lessons from her right and so you know
this is a picture that could be taken in
a lot of places in South Dakota we've
got grass and bison and so you've got a
diversity of plant species in this
picture you've got some of them that are
green some are brown so some are
actively growing some are not we've got
an herbivore eating it this this and we
could imagine that there are they're not
in the picture but the antelope are just
over the hill and the rabbits are hiding
in the grass and the you know we've got
all lots of different we've got lots of
diversity both plants and animals and
this is what built up our soils right
this is what gave our soils fertility
and if we think about the flows of
nutrients here there wasn't there was
hardly any export right because the
animals eat stuff and they're not
shipping it across the ocean to another
country they're not we're not taking
stuff very far away and that's a that's
a real key factor and if we dive into a
little bit of the details of that if we
talk about nitrogen for instance there's
a lot of nitrogen in the atmosphere and
gets into the soil plants can take it up
this is a picture of a lead plan which
is the legumes like enough alpha or P or
soybean you know it's gonna along with
the bacteria it's gonna fix nitrogen
when that nitrogen or when that plant is
consumed by the animal in fact very
little of that nitrogen stays in the
animal almost all of it is going to
leave the animal in feces in urine and
go back to the soil and if we look at
what those actual percentages are we've
got the the retained nitrogen and this
is on pounds per acre here so it's only
about a pound or two per acre retained
and this you know to do to put numbers
to this sort of thing you have to make
some assumption so I said 10 hit 10
acres per head for six months and what's
the nitrogen that's retained well if you
have a growing animal nitrogen is a key
component of muscle right so that's
where most of that nitrogen is going to
end up so if you've got a you know a
stock or calf or something out there
that's growing that's that the nitrogen
is going to that if you've got a mature
cow her she's not really changing much
in weight so she's not keeping a lot of
the nitrogen but if she's got a calf at
her side and that calf is growing that
cat when that when you sell that calf
you're taking nitrogen away right but
it's not very much it's not very much
nitrogen relative to what they ate most
of what they the nitrogen they eat stays
in your field or pasture in the form of
urine and feces all right now suppose
you put that calf into a feedlot instead
well if we again we have to make some
assumptions so what I said here is well
suppose you had a 500 pound calf and you
fed him to gain at a rate of 2.1 pounds
per day now that's a pretty low gain for
a feedlot but but let's just so so
basically what I'm giving you is a kind
of a baseline scenario kind of a
best-case scenario if you want to feed
that calf and you have no waste so again
that's not realistic right it's going to
take 56 pounds of nitrogen so you're
going to take 56 pounds of nitrogen off
field and bring it over here to the
feedlot to feed the calf and that's
best-case scenario at the same time that
that and when I say you're taking it off
you know you're taking it off in the hay
or the grain or whatever you're feeding
that calf that's how much nitrogen you
need if you don't waste anything you're
also taking off a lot of phosphorus and
the nitrogen you can get back from the
atmosphere the phosphorus you're not
getting it back from the atmosphere it's
gone once you take it away and and then
you're taking off a lot of organic
matter too now in contrast if you look
over here if you these are what the
numbers look like if rather than taking
it from the field and giving it to the
calf in the feedlot what if you took the
calf and you put him over here in the
field so everything he eats all the
manure and urine and everything is going
back onto the land well when he's after
six months that calf has grown and
that's why you're still taking away some
of the nitrogen and some of the
phosphorus and some of the organic
matter but you're keeping a lot more on
your land and if we take a look if we
just subtract these numbers like 56
minus nine and six minus two I've got
that on this next slide what's the
difference well 47 pounds of nitrogen if
it cost 30 cents a pound
you know that's worth 14 dollars how
much is the phosphorus worth 340 and
this is elemental phosphorus not p2o5
so you've got $17.50 roughly worth of
nutrients just in nitrogen of phosphorus
and then organic matter I know it's very
valuable but I didn't put a number there
because I know whatever price I put in
for it was going to be wrong so I don't
want us to forget about the value of the
organic matter so with that in mind then
that to me that presents the challenge
of that I've got stated up here how long
can we keep our animals and the
nutrients that they eat on the land so
to me that's that's the question that's
the challenge that we have to look at so
specifically what are we doing at Dakota
Lakes this is something that we're we're
just beginning to try
these are electronic feeding stalls and
they're actually designed to be used in
a dairy
if we flip around and look at them from
the back this is the end that the cow
would come in so she walks in there this
Green Deal reads an electronic ID that
she's got on her hanging from her neck
and it says oh this is you know Cal
number 326 and today she's gonna get her
Ashton of its a pound of corn and then a
pound of peas and a half a pound of
soybean meal and it's so it's tailored
specifically to this animal so if I've
got a sixteen hundred pound cow out
there and I've got an eleven hundred
pound cow out there there they can get
different amounts of supplement based on
their needs same thing if I'm trying to
fatten calves out on on field and and
pasture and I've got it you know a six
hundred pound calf and a nine hundred
pound calf with different nutrient
requirements they can get different
levels of supplement and the way we've
got three right up here there's one two
three of these little black things with
the yellow sticker on them that's that's
where the feed comes down so we can
actually provide three different kinds
of supplement in any combination that we
want any mixture that we want and we
envision that these things will move
around field and pasture with the cows
and that's where this comes in Duane and
Jim Jim's our fabricator Jim's they've
been working on designs Jim has mounted
this solar panel on top of an irrigator
and so we envision that this will also
have shade on it it'll pull those
feeders around we may have the water a
point getting pulled around with it we
eventually maybe we can build other
things on like scales and fly control
things like this and if we can because
if we can move this around the pasture
we can get better grazing distribution
and we can get we can have that urine
and the manure spread out all over the
pasture all over the field rather than
having it all end up in the you know the
one spot where you set the feeders right
so with any with any luck we'll have
this operating
time this summer now what have we been
doing visiting to kind of run through a
year in the life of the cattle at Dakota
lakes here what kind of what are they
eating at different times of the year
and what what's the quality they're
early in the year we start on those
exotic cool season pastures the crested
wheat grass and the smooth bromb they're
very very good that time of year and
then we as we get into June and July we
tend to we transition more to our tall
grass our native tall grass species like
the switchgrass and this one in this
particular picture you can see we
actually interceded some peas and it was
a kind of basically a cover crop mixture
into the switchgrass they didn't
actually graze this until early July but
I can tell you they they really enjoyed
being out there with the combination of
the tall grasses and those cover crops
it was a good diet in this picture when
we are grazing the tall grasses we we
prefer to move the fence pretty
frequently and you can definitely tell
in this picture where the fence was
yesterday right right there and at this
point it's July 30th the quality of this
is quite low the crude protein is
getting to be down pretty marginal even
for a dry cow and so it may require this
time of year may require some crude
protein supplementation another thing we
did in the middle of the summer was on
the the pivot corners we had some cover
crop swaths and we grazed those and
being that it was in the middle of the
summer you can see dates down here going
from late July to late August it was hot
and it was humid and those are great
conditions for breaking down organic
matter right so I was wondering what was
going to happen to the quality of these
swaths over the summer and that's why I
took samples at several different times
and you can see that for crude protein
you know we lost a couple percent points
of crude protein and tdn that's the
energy content stands for total
digestible nutrients so that's the
energy or the calories you know it's
what you need to put pounds on to on an
animal
and we can see you can see we lost some
quality there too just over the course
of a month as we get into week Ave in
August and September and on this
particular field this is a dryland field
not irrigated and we got to forage crops
off of it and so the first forage crop
was we bailed up and set aside and in
fact before we bailed it we while the
swaths were on the ground we went
through and we drilled the the next crop
which was the German militancy here in
the foreground and so then when we were
ready to graze it with our cows that are
calving we started putting the bales
back out onto the the field and so
they've got a mixture of you know they
can graze the bales and they've also got
some of the German millet we moved the
fence every day for this too so we kind
of ration it out little by little and it
worked very well this year with rain now
this is a picture taken from the same
spot last year when it was very dry it
did not it didn't work quite as well but
we got the first crop we got the bales
but we didn't have enough moisture to
get that second forage crop the idea was
the same in fact I think I think the
previous two years it did not work very
well this year worked excellent so back
to this year or to 2019 this is the same
field from the other direction you can
see you know all the manure that we're
leaving behind here just what we wanted
to do they also had access at the same
time to some standing corn to graze and
as you can see we that was we fed a lot
of soil we fed the cows with it but we
fed the soil quite a lot to a lot of it
gets trampled but they I think they had
just gotten into this area so they would
be able to clean that up a little bit
better I mean the cows would eat a
little bit more of it that's on the
ground there and the other thing is that
they we gave them some switchgrass
there's a so at the same time they had
access to all three of these different
crops and the switchgrass at this time
of year it's not that good of quality
and so it's providing it's more of a
bedding sort of probably but it was
interesting to me
see that they still ate some of it and
it just goes to show that I mean we all
like some diversity in our diet even
chocolate cake if you hate it for every
meal every day you get tired of it
eventually and cattle are no different
you know they like to have some
diversity in their diet moving into
September now we grazed a standing cover
crop and the quality on this was just
fabulous you know 26% crude protein and
64% digestible nutrients okay now where
as we're getting close to the winter one
of the questions we've been asking in
the last couple years is about
fertilizing or not fertilizing our cover
crops and this is a picture from 2018
and I put this in here because you can
really see the difference between the
you know fertilize and not fertilize you
can see these strips out there however
when I actually went out and took
collected the samples I couldn't find
very much difference in in yield between
the fertilized and the non fertilized
strips
you know sometimes our eyes can be be
deceiving but another thing but there I
mean there's definitely some impact
there or I mean you can see it you can
see that there's some impact but it was
not as dramatic as you might think and
in fact the statistics said that there
really wasn't a difference in how much
grew but another thing we noticed is
that where we've fertilized we see this
we got green up again so the Fertile I
the strips that had been fertilized
after we swath they they they grew and
greened up and where we had not
fertilized they did not but that didn't
really add a whole lot of biomass to the
equation in terms of forage or soil
health so we did it again this year and
this year it besides going out there by
hand and cutting stuff and weighing it
and all that I also used a drone to take
images and we got you know the regular
visible light images we also use some
near infrared cameras and calculated a
NDVI which is supposed to tell us how
much is out there
and so I did both the drone and the hand
sampling and on this particular field
which is not irrigated you can see the
yields that we've got here 3,000 pounds
per acre fertilized 2,400 pounds per
acre not fertilized but whether I
collected my data with the drone or by
hand the statistics say there's no
difference there that was hard for me to
believe and I'll get a little bit more
into that in a minute but the other
thing we see is that the fertilized part
had a little higher crude protein and so
that's also beneficial but again the
statistics didn't didn't support me
there and saying that there's really a
difference but statistics aside we've
got a 25% increase here going from not
fertilized to fertilized and if we
calculate just on the non fertilized
part it costs us 62 dollars per ton if
we assume that we had to hire someone to
go out there and do all the field
operations and that and bought the seed
and everything 62 dollars per ton using
custom rates and then if we if we
consider that we put on 45 pounds of
nitrogen and the extra forage we got for
that the use of fertilizer it cost us
$59 per ton for those that extra tonnage
so neither one of these is bad a bad
price for the quality of this forage we
did the same thing on one of our
irrigated fields
it did get irrigated one time 3/4 of an
inch is all and on this field the yields
are very similar 3,100 pounds of 2200
pounds very similar to the other field
to the field that was not irrigated at
this time though the statistics support
the difference and they say yeah yeah
there really is a difference you know
the fertilizer really did something and
we see it in the crude protein also and
so cost per ton for the non fertilize is
similar you know $68 per ton to produce
the non fertilized but then with the
addition of fertilizer it cost us forty
dollars per ton the cost of that
fertilizer to produce some extra forage
so again good prices for this high
quality forage so what we do with it
then this is following wheat we've
planted this cover crop
and we're planning to graze it over the
winter and we swath almost all of it and
if we have the cows eat the swaths Duane
also left some standing strips this year
so we can make a comparison between the
swaths and the strip's but mostly it's
just the swaths you can see 11 days
later this picture I took now a lot of
the green has faded out of that out of
that standing crop and me a lot of you
are probably familiar with this but with
the way we prefer to move the fences
over the winter is with the irrigator so
we don't have to be moving posts all
along you can see the the white wires
those are our hot wires there they're
hanging from the irrigator and so you go
out there and you press the button on
the irrigator and it moves your fence
four or twenty feet or whatever so we've
got the swaths running one direction and
the fence running perpendicular to it
like this and we just move that fence
along the line so the cows get an extra
20 feet or whatever the number is you
know every day we just give them a
little bit more ration it out to them if
you take in a tour at Dakota Lakes
you've probably been on top of our calf
shelter here on the backs that you can't
see in this picture about the backside
of it there's a piece that we can flap
down and then it covers up the backside
the calves can get in there here you can
see the defense is back here in this
picture and this undisturbed snow right
here the cows haven't been there yet you
can see yesterday this is the area they
were working in and so here's a swath
you can see this swath in the foreground
that they were eating and they haven't
bothered the snow near as much in
between and then here's another swath
the cows are they do a fine job of
finding it and if you think about the
grazing the swath versus grazing the
standing if you've got a 20 foot swath
or you take all that 20 feet and you
condense it down into two feet right and
now if there's no snow that doesn't make
a whole lot of difference but once it
starts to snow and cover that up now the
cow only has to search these two feet
where the swath is right and so the kind
of the action
does she she reaches down in there and
she kind of takes a bite and at the sit
and then she actually picks her head up
she kind of flips some of the snow to
the side and she reaches down she picks
it takes a bite and she kind of flips
them and so he's almost like she's
tunneling along where that swath is
moving the snow to the side and because
we're moving this fence every day she
can see where that swath was yesterday
and she knows where to look for it
tomorrow now you get a bunch of new snow
or if it you cross over on top sometimes
you might have to come through and help
them out a little and maybe drive over
top and they can see where it is or they
so they can kind of get in there get
that first bite in there and start
working at it but they don't they don't
come at it from above they come at it
you know from the the side horizontally
and they work through it that direction
the cat you know the calves even get out
there and do it because we're fall
calving so we've got the calves out
there eating swathes - so I did the same
thing here as I did during the summer
with those swaths I went out every month
and I collected quality samples to see
what's happening and of course during
the winter we expect it to be preserved
better than during the summer so with
those cold temperatures we expect the
quality to be maintained versus the the
hot humid summer and and that's pretty
much what we see we lost a couple
percentage points just like in the
summer but it took three months to lose
it rather than one month and the
difference between the you know one of
these is standing one is swath well you
know there's a little bit of difference
here but there's a lot of variability in
the data not not much difference between
them in terms of quality the difference
I think is mostly in the cows ability to
get to it I also measured the tdn again
remember this is the energy or the
calories that's in it and we see a
decline over these several months but
and this is one field I collected the
data on another field - and if we look
at this second field the loss of crude
protein isn't much at all same with the
the energy not a whole lot of loss of
energy so we can see that we do lose
some quality in these swaths over the
winter but it's not real dramatic
and it's better than the summer so
besides giving the swaths every day we
also give them some some corn residue
every day and the the swaths are
high-quality and if that's all the cows
got it would be a great diet the corn
residue is not as good at quality and
but it provides some fill and they do
find some some ears in there that the
combine missed and so you put those two
together the diets not as good as what
we'd like the cows to have over winter
and so we also give them a little bit of
supplement which could be in the form of
flaxseed meal soybean meal that we
produce on the farm could also be you
know it could be corn or peas or lentil
sorghum this is another drone image that
I took and this is on a a corn field you
can see this spot up here where we had
some really wet soils this year and all
this this part of the field is on the
right that got planted later because it
was wet and so from the drone imagery
you can definitely see those differences
and this is this is supposed to be
telling us where we had more corn or
less corn right I also have cages out
there with that we don't let the cows
into because and I do this on a lot of
the fields where we let the cows graze
to find out what kind of impact they're
having and so I thought and I go out
there and I harvest with I do some hand
harvesting or some small plot combines
to harvest those and try to compare
yields to say well if we had a cow out
here last year you know is it hurting
our corn yield is it hurting our soybean
yield and so far I haven't been able to
find any differences so this year I
enlisted a drone to help me out
and the drone couldn't find the
differences either so so I'm I have not
been able to find evidence of the
grazing hurting our yields at Dakota
lakes and I so so how do I explain that
I know some there are some people who
have said that they have had trouble and
I I don't have a scientific study where
I set this up to make the compare
and yet but I suspect that what's
happening is it's the particularly that
we're managing things at Dakota Lakes
you know these soils have been in
long-term no-till for decades and the
way we graze those cover crops is first
we have a wheat crop and we harvest it
with a stripper head and this is a
picture of what the soil looks like you
know we have I mean look at that you
mean it's just completely covered with
the straw from from the wheat and then
we've we've got our cover crop in here
and the cover crop gets gets swathed and
concentrated in one spot but that ground
is still covered with the wheat straw so
when our cows are out there they're
stepping on that armor the wheat straw
is the armor and the other thing is
we're moving these fences everyday right
and so they're never staying in one spot
for a long time and if we do get really
soft soils you know it's some moisture
and the soils are not frozen well tend
to move the cows off of that field and
put them into a perennial grass area for
a while and feed them some bales but
even if they're you know if everything
doesn't always work out perfectly it's a
you know the Dakota Lakes it's a real it
so even though we do a lot of research
there we have this challenge as everyone
does and sometimes the cows are on the
field when it's the soils a little bit
soft you know and you can see some hoof
prints but even then we're moving that
fence every day so they're not camped
out in one spot beating that soil to
death for a month at a time and I so
that's what I that's the speculation as
to why we're having the success we are
so that is the end of my presentation
and but I just wanted to post this
question up here again at the end the
challenge that I see is how long can we
keep our animals and then nutrients they
eat in our land and I hope that the all
those stars form the constellation the
marketing part and the the read the beef
label in the back you know how that if
we can get a higher if we can get a
premium for doing the good things we do
for the land and keeping the cattle on
the land and the nutrients on the land
and there again
matter on the land hopefully we can we
can bring that all together so I should
have time for a few questions at least
if there are any yes sir on the question
was on the shields pastor when we did
the grazing how many head were out there
we have thirty cows and so you know from
year to year plus or minus thirty cows
and the whole that whole pasture is
around eighty acres but that part where
we're doing the experiment we tent we
have them in paddocks that are less than
an acre like the smaller some of the
small paddocks are about two-tenths of
an acre and then the larger ones are
about four times that I think so just
just under an acre so 30 cows and in
that area so it's not it's not as
intensive as some of the really high
stocking rate mob grazing but it is much
more intensive than typically what you
would see
any more questions okay thank you very
much going right thank you
[Applause]